so I was supposed to fly in for my
buddy's bachelor party which was the
week before his wedding and then
National Party what was it yeah uh
Scotland
or no no Newcastle Newcastle and then
the second day in Scotland he had a
[__] bachelor party in Newcastle I
know I was so [__] pumped to go to
this and you guys went airsofting for 10
hours no I got [__] covered
you tested yes dude loser
well because
last thing in 2023 is because my [__]
wife is pregnant yeah and we're staying
in a [__] tiny ass hotel room
together all right so I tested before I
left it was negative I was like [__]
yeah right because I felt like [__] and
I was like hey whatever
don't have coven I'm good this is just a
little sickness I'll get over it
tomorrow for sure and I land
like a fever is starting I'm like
[__] God damn it I still had a test
in my bag so we checked into the hotel
bring our bags in or whatever
and then I I'm like I should test myself
again test myself again I I like you
know use a little dripper and I drip
like two little snot things in there the
[__] line goes like neon pink
immediately it was like a double
positive I've never had that I was like
oh my God before the control line turns
pink yeah it the test line Auto like
Bing you have it that's like when we
were in Detroit and you tested for the
flu and the guy's like oh yeah you're
serious [__] exactly
wait two things he was like get away
from me two things one just for everyone
again
I test still I do test I tested a couple
weeks ago all right
um
secondly
you're one of the first one of the very
first ones to experience a mask
in that era
like you you went to that clinic you're
like I think I have the flu Oh when I
had the flu doctor tested Cody
naked face came back in the room with
the mat masked up and was like you're
sick as [__] you get the [__] out of
here yeah that's what he basically told
me so you test Uber pot you test Uber
God damn it so we got another room for
Kelsey
so the this [__] portion of the trip
ended up being twice as expensive and I
didn't get to go to the bachelor party
what was the bachelor party like they
went shooting they shot like clay or
whatever yeah you know like pull yeah
they uh did a whiskey tasting in
Scotland they [__] went out in
Newcastle my they put my buddy in like
the [__] Newcastle fit like with the
tight ass jeans oh and like a polo done
up to here nice the chain around nice
dude is so [__] funny nice so they
had a night out in Newcastle which I was
stoked for because I wanted to like hear
the accents and come back and be like I
[__] went yeah no hassle Newcastle
you know with those who are those
he said and instead I was in a [__]
hotel room the AC was broken and I
didn't realize that until the third day
AC don't work in Europe no but I picked
this hotel specifically because it has
AC I looked it up online I know I know I
know no I trust you down to the Google
like you know when you're on Google
hotels I trust and I like clicked
amenities and I clicked the drop down
yeah and I'm reading all them okay we're
doing [__] laundry whatever it is
yeah
AC check oh my God book yeah
so I'm sitting there alone on my
European Vacation alone because my
wife's in a different [__] room in
the same building yeah
sweating my ass off yeah and I decided
to watch top boy yeah you ever seen that
show I haven't started it
it's it's amazing but it's so [__]
depressing there's zero redeemable
things that happen on that show yeah
it's just like kids die from gang
violence yeah so I'm sitting there just
sweating and then sweating my ass off in
this room alone
thinking I'm going crazy because the
wind the air is blowing out of the vents
but it's just not cold oh yeah so keep
going to check it
you know I'm fever I'm sore as [__] I
keep getting up I'm like [__] [__]
think it's on but I don't want to call
anyone up because I'm sick
watching kids die they trick you I don't
think they realize AC means like has to
blow cold air they don't believe in ice
they don't believe in
aircon
it's crazy it's just hot over there yeah
they're just constantly sticky that's
why the European sex goes crazy yeah
that's you think that's what it is I
mean when you have sex in Europe it's
musty it's passionate it's like it's
just reeks like cigarettes yeah yeah
because you're just filthy yeah yeah
you're both disgusting yeah that's so
true I've been watching this like
grundle sweat
just sharing Gooch sweat and musk and
cigarette breath just like scooping the
duck ew duck butter
hey don't look at me Trevor heard that
song about duck butter no it's not
that's truffle butter the same [__] dude
we know what we're talking about no no
but did you just make that up no look up
duck butter man duck butter deep that's
so much worse than truffle butter
that's what it sounds like when you
sounds like a duck when you scoop it off
your gooch
duck butter has a slang turned their
first to sweat semen I don't know I
don't know magma was in the mix duck
butter oh I didn't know this is European
Sexes I heard I don't know why well
maybe think of this Trot the saying
truffle did I think but somebody in the
bachelor party he was saying that
he was referring to people that
Like Cocaine as truffle pigs
uh you're a bunch of truffle pigs just
sniffing that [__] out
that's really funny
yeah that's the that is yeah Scottish or
UK slang too yeah okay so then the
little baby moon that we did we went to
Taormina yeah yeah which is in Sicily
yeah my friend recommended it and then I
realized it's where White Lotus was
based oh so is that like that's where
the Four Seasons is is there which is
booked up for like five years yeah
but like the stadium that they went to
and all that [__] yeah you were in there
it's all in that like little town
Taormina is [__] beautiful stunning
Town yeah
but we stayed at this really nice hotel
and it just felt exactly the same as
White Lotus like I just felt like the
[__] American the whole time
like I was gonna ask for the pineapple
sweet or some [__] like that yeah and
they're all dressed up in those like
suits and they're like
I walk in the lobby
bonjourno and this smile like way too
hard at you and I just felt like a
[__] the whole time yeah like just a
[__] American yeah you know do you
have a plug adapter plug what yeah the
plug the power
for my shaver
you know I gotta shave my bush
just like that we've done shave our
pubes here I don't know yeah we got it
we gotta install some like Motel 6
workers over there in Europe yeah really
uh
but at the Four Seasons and stuff really
take Americans back down to Peg yeah
you try calling for service at a at a
Motel 6 in Kansas City how do you guys
have water yes down here yeah yeah
oh is there gonna bring it up to the
room no nope
but you can come on down and get it
I personally love nothing more than
going down into the lobby of a [__]
of a Hyatt
or you know like a between motel and
fancy hotel like a business Motel yeah
yeah business day Hotel love going to
the lobby and getting my chilies yeah
yeah yeah Chili's travels really well on
doordash you know what else does Nando's
oh yeah yeah
yeah I was gonna say you probably had
some of that oh yeah so good what did
you [__] get that stinks
it smells like garlic I just got a bunch
of garbage